foreign
no other place like home
it's a small town we just want to be
able to take care of our own Banks come
and they go why this one is leaving is
not being explained
[Music]
people were wondering what are we gonna
do that's just one more negative against
us that we didn't have anything to do
with that we can't help
[Music]
you have to go back to how Banks started
right and who they were created to serve
redlining basically isolated
African-American people for you know
almost 100 years when you have unequal
access to the banking system you end up
with unequal outcomes in Mississippi
there are actually more payday lenders
per capita than Starbucks there's cash
on top no credit checks instant approval
those those are some of the terms that
they use my banking is important my
dollars matter the social contract with
banks has been broken
[Music]
is a great place to live we have school
systems or Courthouse drug stores we
have other businesses that uh
keeping us alive and well they just need
more people involved with the growth
process the beautification process
we got to notice early part of the year
so we have 90 days we're closing we're
moving out there was a notify all people
that had accounts there it was very
shocking in a sense
elderly
was really crime because it's commute
the business were complaining it's just
difficult to handle business here when
we don't have banking
so where are we going now this is the
deal
it's most what like the most recent
restaurant that opened here
we were voted in the top five best beef
burgers in Mississippi last year
it's a very much a community place I
like living in Coffeeville a lot more
than I would probably like to admit as
far as the town you can't find better
people that work together and mostly get
along it's just hard when you're losing
everything and you have to go somewhere
else for everything
before the Bank closed they were
literally two blocks from us so I could
send somebody walking to go get change
if we needed it
and now I have to drive 20 25 minutes
one way it doesn't seem like it would be
that big a deal but you can't even just
go to the other businesses and swap
change because they have to keep what
they've got and then you have to be a
female driving all that way with that
whole week's deposit by yourself you get
a little nervous people pay attention
they know when you're coming and going
they know where you're going so it's
definitely been a hardship how does that
make you feel hearing that your
community is a big investment I am
heartbroken for Coffeeville because
that's such a negative thing to have
attached to our name when we really are
good people
hello Mr Taylor
it's got some visitors here
my name is Jermaine Taylor I am a screen
printer I make both t-shirts everything
is in book I've been doing it
self-employed eight years here in
Coffeeville
it's located it's just actually
footsteps away from the bank I didn't
have to worry about spending money in
gas or anything like that I don't make
deposits every day or twice a day
anymore sometimes it's once a week
sometimes it's the next week later and
that becomes a security issue there's
plenty of money in this town and it's
definitely not a desert town
my wife and I own the local newspaper
here in Coffeyville it's called the
Coffeyville Courier my business is a
little different from everybody else's
the hamburger place sells hamburgers I
sell advertising well that depends on
this town to advertise for different
things
promote their business to help promote
our school well if businesses are
closing or businesses won't come here
because of the banking issues
the net hurts it hurts everybody and you
take away the business side of it and
just look at the community itself
but made it hard on the citizens young
and older life
people were wondering what are we going
to do what happens to our money that's
in this bank we need a bank if I wanted
to buy a house I need a bank to be able
to go in and sit down and speak with a
loan officer the federal government has
designated Coffeeville as a banking
desert how does that make you feel
unimportant
neglected in some way
like a second-class citizen and I'm not
I am important my banking is important
my dollars matter
bacon is pretty well the lifeline of
this community right now everybody's
wanting a bank they want businesses they
want housing but they're crying about
the bank
[Music]
there are less branches in Black
communities less branches in low-income
communities and so when a branch closes
it has a disproportionate impact we've
seen about 7 000 branches close since
2017 about 4 000 since the start of the
pandemic in March of 2020 so the pace of
Branch closures has really accelerated
which is partially driven by the fact
that people are doing more Banking
online but it's also driven by you know
by profitability a lot of communities
especially in the southwest of the U.S
Southeast uh you know certain areas in
the midwest that have generally been in
Decline have lost their bank so as Banks
merge they close up their inefficient
branches that's part of the the model
for banking banking deserts exist across
the country but they're more
concentrated in places like the Deep
South in communities of color in inner
city Urban neighborhoods
[Music]
having a relationship a good
relationship with a financial
institution is really what paves the way
and helps people build assets so that
they can also build generational wealth
the primary driver of wealth the primary
asset on most Americans balance sheet is
a home most of the ways in which
Americans build wealth involves
borrowing money so when you have unequal
access to the banking system you end up
with unequal outcomes the inequality
comes not from your great great
grandfather it comes from who got to own
a home in 1950. who was being helped by
the federal government who add access to
that Capital it's historical we have to
get
a good understanding of why people act
the way they act I like to tell the
story of the Freedmen's Bank
when we look at inequality in America we
see pretty deep divides on the basis of
race a lot of that comes from access to
banking services both historical and in
present day
African Americans have had a long
history in this country of being denied
opportunity to financial structures and
institutions so you can go to slavery
you could go to the post-slavery period
called reconstruction in America where
there was the creation of the freedmen
bank and the creation of some
institutions to help African Americans
the result of the Civil War was the
collapse of the Southern banking system
the United States Army still occupied
the South and so they had all of these
soldiers many of them who were
African-American and they had to figure
out how do they pay them so one of the
things was to create a bank the
Freedmen's Bureau bank which allowed the
government to pay these soldiers but
also to set up a means for the newly
freed to save their money it was a big
name institution based right here in
Washington DC right next to the White
House millions of dollars were saved by
these newly free people a lot of the
people in the community at the time were
under the impression that their savings
and their wages would be federally
insured what happened was with the
Freedmen's Bank it took a series of
really risky bets on railroads on other
Investments it went bankrupt and lost
everybody all their money so there's you
know really good reasons why people uh
distrust the banking system
why is there a gap between communities
of color and banks in this country and I
think what you find is that oftentimes
there is a lack of trust I was born in
1940.
people in my community they didn't trust
the banks because the banks collapse the
Urban Development though is crucial to
understand another dimension that Banks
played this is where the wealth of the
21st Century
is being created opportunity to access
to land and capital in urban areas and
the jobs that go with them part of that
is to create these dividing lines that
the banks underwrote
in creating these segregated housing
patterns how do we do that well we build
massive subdivisions which end up
replicating the patterns that have been
put in place at the beginning of the
20th century and these maps that are
drawn by the federal agencies charged
with this have rare behinds to indicate
these aren't good neighborhoods
redlining refers to practice the banks
the federal government used to have a
really drawing red lines on a map around
certain neighborhoods and Grading every
neighborhood from more desirable to less
desirable nine times out of ten the
places that were redlined that were
deemed to be less desirable were
minority neighborhoods immigrant
neighborhoods and so banks in redlined
communities would not make loans we're
not going to underwrite mortgages for
this community we're not going to insure
houses in this community and we're not
going to give business loans in this
community racial segregation and
discrimination was very much baked into
the credit model the banking model the
racial wealth Gap first of all right
that wealth was very much about you know
housing it's the entire Midwest you know
Southwest Southeast and in inner cities
that were redlined
the flow of capital
repeated into white only neighborhoods
continued to cut off black neighborhoods
you would have Banks saying well this is
a risk decision this is not a race
decision
every single subsidy that built the
middle class whether it's the homestead
loans the farm loans the New Deal
mortgage student loans all of those not
accidentally but explicitly Exempted
certain races black predominantly also
you know Mexican Japanese because 96 to
99 of all mortgages from 1934 until
around 1970 were funded by the FHA that
those neighborhoods never got mortgages
what they got instead were things like
contract loans installment loans they
were paying twice or three times as much
in rent
your school taxes were linked to your
mortgage the roads the parks all of the
goodies of the sort of make America
great was provided through those
subsidized mortgages and that is sort of
the the American dream and it was very
much financed by the federal government
and if you were not a white male
Breadwinner you did not get that loan
our Studies have shown that 70 percent
of communities that were redlined in the
1930s are still low income today land
ownership sits at the basis of all
capital and so that history of not being
treated equally or fairly in our system
is what caused the racial wealth Gap
[Music]
those relationships with financial
institutions at the very Foundation the
relationships themselves have not been
created or nurtured and so you find that
in many communities of color they rely
on other alternative lenders in the
absence of a of a bank or credit union
the payday lender is the check cashers
the financial Predators come in and fill
the Gap I said that there were two
banking systems right one that is
incredibly federally subsidized that
plugs in directly to the fed and that
system largely serves those who have
wealth or have enough money to put in a
bank account and then there's this whole
other wild west system
[Music]
[Music]
we look right across the street there's
one here right on the corner
it says cash on the top no credit checks
instant approval those those are some of
the terms that they use
I really believe that with the payday
lending places
the advantage that they have
is this instant and they can just go in
and get a loan and come right back out
with it but not thinking long term how
it really affects them and how it really
puts them back in the hole in
Mississippi there are actually more
payday lenders per capita than Starbucks
payday lenders they are creative they
will pop up in the smallest of places it
is simply put a way for people to have
access to small dollar amounts they're
Limited at 500 here in the state on a
short-term basis typically 30 days or
less with incredibly High interest rates
in Mississippi that's 521 APR that
oftentimes the principles never be paid
and people just end up in a spiral
spiraling trap of debt that can take
years or decades to break out of
foreign
[Music]
on these kind of piecemeal Solutions
instead of kind of a One-Stop Financial
servicer I.E a bank means that you do
end up spending a lot more money for
basic Services what is it about the
Delta region that draws these predatory
lenders here I don't think it's a secret
when we look at Mississippi and how it's
ranked amongst everything Health Care
education pretty much ranked the last on
a lot of things so it's not surprising
to me that large employees or
corporations would take advantage of a
population that they think is not
educated enough to understand what
they're getting themselves into
we're here to talk about financial
planning how to create wealth how to
keep your money and the do's and don'ts
of your money it's very important
especially coming from a small town
because we don't have a whole lot here
and we're actually trying to build the
community up for the younger generation
that's coming along and if they don't
know ways to actually make money and be
able to create generational wealth then
the towns the small town and the town
surrounding will continue to go down
from my experience I don't think most
banks here in Mississippi are fair to
a lot of loners I just think that
if there's a system for loners it should
be a system for everybody and not for
one group of people we use a lot of
little Community Banks around here
others prefer not to use Banks why do
you think people go to the payday
lenders instead of a bank because it's
easier to get money from them than it is
from the bank because if your credit is
not a certain thing sometimes the banks
won't let you get the money I've tried
to you know buy a house and it was just
one thing after another we need your
bank statement we need your your bills
what did you do in 20 2015 what happened
why you weren't working
I've been trying to get a house in 2015.
I tried to get a house in 2021. why
can't we talk about what I'm doing now
an areas that are kind of run down or
have a lot of poor you know not really
middle-class people they feel like they
can feed off of that because they know
that they don't have the money
especially if you live in paycheck to
paycheck I don't know it's just hard
it's hard and it hurts because you know
you want to do so much for your family
and you know your kids see you hurting
and they see you want to do better and
they see you you know struggling and
they you know Mom what's wrong what's
going on
foreign
all of our products and services are
regulated at both the state level and
the federal level what we offer is
basic financial services that are
transparent that are convenient that are
cost effective and that provide a bridge
for our customers
odd of informality they all kind of have
different signs and it looks to be
embedded in the community they will have
two payday lenders owned by the same
company on the same block with different
signs pretending like they're different
companies right so that's a model that
that is that is used many of our
customers are either subprime customers
or have thin or no credit files so that
they are
somewhat of a um a greater risk here's
what payday lenders do that Banks don't
right so payday lenders and check
cashers have their fees listed usually
and each week you may pay fifty dollars
to renew that loan now that is an absurd
interest rate to keep rolling over that
loan but it's predictable with banks
there are you know pages and pages of
legalese and jargon that is like
purposefully meant to vary that APR rate
or that they may change the fees uh one
month to the next our customers are
intelligent they on understand their
financial lives to assume that our
customers get trapped is a criticism of
our customers
an annual percentage rate contemplates
that alone will be outstanding for a
year our products are often paid off in
a much shorter period of time that
annual percentage rate will distort the
actual cost of the credit
[Music]
also here with us today is the great
Bill Vina the CEO of Hope Credit Union
[Music]
and Mr Bynum as you know has helped
connect so many people in Mississippi
and across the South with the
opportunity
and yes with hope we were very excited
to be able to host vice president Harris
earlier this year invited her to come to
the Delta to see firsthand the
opportunities that exist and how the
administration could leverage its
efforts alongside Community Development
Finance institutions like hope
in many of the towns that hope is
located many neighborhoods we're located
we are the only financial institution 80
of our branches are in community of
color 30 are in rural areas credit
unions and Banks differ in some
fundamental ways but mostly is who owns
the institution all credit unions are
owned by their members whether you have
a million dollars or ten dollars in
deposits you have one vote for the board
and for key policy decisions I think in
many cases financial institutions often
don't know their neighborhoods or
communities well enough particularly
communities of color and so they
actually need cdfis as partners to help
them not only identify the need but to
come up with Solutions on providing
affordable access and credit to
underserved communities
I described a Delta Region as an amazing
part of this country It produced some of
the most Innovative people not just BB
King or the writers and the musicians
and artists but just imagine people who
do so much who survive with less so
there's systemic disparities in the
banking system black entrepreneurs are
three times more likely to report that
they did not apply for credit for fear
of being turned away by a bank
black and Latino homeowners are rejected
at a higher rate when applying for home
loans
from traditional financial institutions
even when they have credit profiles
similar
to other applicants we've been fortunate
to be able to go into communities in
many cases where banks have closed and
convert those Banks into a Credit Union
branch one great example is Morehead
Mississippi
[Music]
hello tail hi thanks for having us yeah
well it's good it's good to have you
guys here uh in our small community my
name is George Holland again and I'm the
mayor here in the town of Moorhead I've
been married for 14 years I was born
here my family was sharecroppers it was
13 of us in a small house two and a half
miles east of Morehead Morehead is known
for where the Southern Cross the yellow
dog those two railroads across here in
Moorhead and that was at back in the
early 1900s late 1800s everything moved
by rail
so Moorhead started out to be the
largest community the largest city in in
the Delta when I was a kid this town was
hustling bustling it was a real uh
productive town Friday evening and
Saturday evening if you couldn't hardly
walk down these streets for for the
traffic for people but now it's just
dead when I went to Moorhead to talk to
Mayor Holland and tell him that the bank
branch was closed he invited me to get
in his truck and drove me around the
town he showed me the community he
showed me a neighborhood called eastmoor
where homes had been built in the 70s to
bring the workers the black former
Plantation workers closer in town so
that it would be more accessible to the
businesses that relied on them but it
was built outside the city limits
interestingly largely because they
wanted to limit the impact of those
residents on on local elections and the
houses were built it will build terrible
quality and didn't take long before you
saw running sewage in the streets there
were electrical fires some people died
in some of those fires we were able to
work with the mayor work with some of
our partners and bring Capital into
those Community into that community and
we ultimately have renovated every home
in that neighborhood that's what a bank
does that's what a bank should do it is
the primary economic engine for many
communities particularly in small towns
and I believe it was like
2015. it's hope field avoid that really
really changed things here in this
community
we're in a bank lease we'll try to
negotiate a contribution both of the
facility and of financial resources to
help us to invest in getting that grants
to a level where it can perform as a
community development Finance
institution and in some cases we've been
able to work with institutions that have
been open to that in other cases we've
had to go to the Senate and to house and
ask policy makers to hold them
accountable because there are laws that
require that Banks reinvest in
communities where they extract the
profit
thank you
I think banking is a utility just like
water you know nobody would think about
cutting out a water that goes to
everybody's house if you don't have
access to credit you really can't fully
participate not only in the financial
system but in the Democracy the social
contract with banks has been broken we
give you the Federal Reserve liquidity
and in return you serve the communities
if we're going to support the system let
it serve everybody
I don't think this is a problem that the
market uh should fix it was a problem
created by policy Banks run on policy we
manage Banks through a variety of
different regulations and laws we should
make sure that those laws are serving
the communities that are most vulnerable
there's something called the community
investment
outstanding obligation on banks to serve
low and moderate income communities it
ensures that they both provide basic
banking services there are other tests
that go along with lending and
investment that actually is undergoing a
big review right now in the United
States and so it's really going to be
modernized to take into account the very
different way that banking services are
both delivered and consumed It Was
Written in 1977 and it was to reverse
redlining we hardly had the globalized
digitized system that we have today so
it certainly needs an update it's easier
to
tweak something that exists that it is
to create something new we need to
really just take a look at what's tried
and true what's in place
we are encouraged by the trend which
shows a steady decline in the total
share of unbanked households banks
around the country through American
Bankers Association is really determined
to make progress in bringing not just
the total number down but making sure
that communities of color all across the
nation have a lower percentage of being
unbanked it is still the case that the
average American lives within
um proximity of 25 Bank branches that is
not to say that that is everybody and we
are working hard and acknowledge the
problem it is also true that the
digitization of banking services means
that there is less demand in some cases
for customers to go into Bank branches
the pandemic forced a change in consumer
Behavior things have been talking about
digitization for years and years and
years they want more people to use their
aperture cheaper for them the goal is to
get everyone on digital the problem is
that those very same communities in our
banking deserts don't have Broadband
we're talking about elderly populations
we're talking about tribes we're talking
about places where there aren't the same
kind of systems I think banks will
benefit by really expanding how they
look not only at that population but
those populations that have been
traditionally unbanked or underbanked
but also the opportunities that are
available if they bring them into that
system and help grow the customers
themselves everybody who's outside of
the banking system is a potential
customer and Banks want customers one of
the most important Solutions we see
that's really bearing fruit is
encouraging our banks to offer what are
called Bank on certified accounts a
basic bank account that is fully
functional but it also has a special set
of guard rails so that people who are
not experienced with having a bank
account can be completely confident
this really starts with the inability to
access capital and credit you know there
need to be a number of solutions
saying financial literacy is something
needed is not to say that you illiterate
is just to say that you can't be no more
than what your experiences allow you to
be by the time they get out of high
school they should know how to do a
checking account and a savings account
and Etc because this is core to how you
build wealth in America more financial
education and addressing some of that
distrust would go a long way towards
creating a smaller unbanked and
underbanked population
the max ought to take a hard look at
whether or not they can create
mechanisms within themselves to deal
with helping to repair things that are
awry in our system
more than anything else ownership
closes the financial wealth Gap can we
create an instrument here that says we
can put people in housing
but no down payment as we become a
nation that's more Diversified in terms
of our demographics you can't make it if
you have 50 homeownership among black
and Latino families
if African Americans are are excluded
from that Financial mainstream more than
likely they don't have a savings plan to
provide even greater benefits for their
children
that becomes then a community problem
the belief of this country is that if
people worked hard and do the right
thing we all should succeed and we
should all be able to have economic
Mobility but that contract isn't true
for everyone because when people don't
feel like they can be part of the
society the social contract is broken
for them then they operate outside of
that Society if the market isn't
benefiting a majority of people then we
need to rethink what kind of Market we
have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]